you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme wildfires continue
to rage across
southern europe with hot dry weather
conditions set to stay
oxfam warns that an over-reliance on
tree planting by governments to meet
their net zero carbon targets
could cause food prices to jump
and dangers in the deep a new study
shows marine life in the caribbean
is being contaminated by single-use
plastics
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we have
continuing coverage
of the extreme heat wave that's hit
parts of the mediterranean
and in particular the wildfires that
have been caused by the extreme heat
we start with turkey where fires are
continuing to rage across the country
extreme heat conditions have made it
easier for the fires to ignite
and to spread well authorities there
have launched an international appeal
to help tame the fires that have killed
eight people in recent days
thousands of people have been forced to
flee their homes in the south of the
country
with coastal areas amongst the worst
affected
well our special correspondent alex
crawford is in turkey larry in turkey
where firefighters
are trying to prevent the fire from
spreading
there are still lots of pockets of fires
which they're
trying desperately to dampen and put out
with fairly limited success you can see
they're sweeping the fire is sweeping
across the forest
mountains and every time they put out
one lot or try and dampen it down it
moves across
the winds don't help it at all and what
they're trying to do is prevent
the fire from encroaching onto these
tourist
buildings they've been evacuated there's
no one in there but they're trying to
prevent
the loss of of of these buildings and of
the power station which is just a few
kilometers away they have got
some air support but they're urgently
asking for more it's patently
inadequate and there's a lot of anger
about why it's taking so long to bring
all of these fires
under control of fresh ones are breaking
out
all the time we're now in the seventh
day
and if you thought climate change didn't
affect you
then this is probably proof it does with
temperatures soaring and expected to
rise even
more over the next few days and
certainly
long into the week they're saying that
humidity is very low
the forest here is very very
exceptionally dry because of these
exceptional
temperatures and these conditions are
proving to be extremely challenging for
all the firefighters and the authorities
and it's not just turkey that's feeling
the impact of this intense heat
temperatures have reached above 40
degrees celsius in parts of greece with
fires spreading
there too authorities have described the
heat wave as the most intense in more
than
30 years and have advised people to
avoid direct sunlight around
midday well our euro correspondent
michelle clifford is in pacinthos
in rhodes where it's becoming
increasingly inhospitable for residents
and for tourists
well clearly you get high temperatures
in greece over the summer that's part of
the reason people come here
on holiday that this is being called the
worst heat wave in over 30 years because
they've been
persistently high temperatures over a
long period of time
and those temperatures coupled with
strong winds have
created a toxic mix for firefighters and
the military trying to contain
forest blazes now the priority is to
stop those blazes
reaching residential areas but this week
some villages had to be evacuated we
spoke
to some of the residents forced out of
their homes they told us they have
noticed
changes over the summer summer period
things getting hotter
in recent years they ask them why they
think that's happening they said climate
change
they acknowledge that they have a role
to play in uh
making things better reducing their
energy consumption but some said
uh the big polluters have to be taken in
hand by the government now
the greek development minister was here
today he said
climate change absolutely has to be
addressed if we're not going to see
these sorts of events repeated summer
after summer
in today's other climate news saint
lucia's prime minister
philip pierre is urging rich nations to
ramp up climate
finance to caribbean states vulnerable
to hurricanes
the pandemic has hit the caribbean's
tourism-dependent economies
meaning there's less money available to
the islands to build homes that can
withstand the extreme weather
scientists warn global warming is
causing severe hurricanes to become more
frequent
and out of season
changing sea levels can affect how often
volcanic eruptions occur on a greek
island according to a study published
in nature geoscience analyzing the
timings of 36
000 eruptions researchers found there
were more volcanic eruptions when sea
levels fell below
40 meters over half of the world's
volcanoes are islands or coastal
and rising sea levels could put the
populations there at risk
from eruptions and a contest to preserve
the pyramid of the feathered serpent
from climate change has been announced
in mexico
air pollution and acid rain has caused
the pyramid to deteriorate
so entrants have been asked to design a
roof structure that can protect the
ancient monument
the mexican institution of history and
anthropology who launched the contest
say climate change is forcing them to
take drastic measures to conserve the
ruins
governments and businesses have made
commitments to significantly reduce
their greenhouse gas emissions
with many promising to reach net zero in
the coming years
well the new report by oxfam has found
too many of these promises
rely on planting trees and restoring
forests on land
that's needed for crops to feed a
growing population
it estimates it could push global food
prices up by 80 percent
by 2050. well here to explain more is
danny srikanda raja chief executive of
oxfam
gb uh welcome to you so explain to us a
bit more the downsides of using
tree planting as a way to reach net zero
goals what are your concerns
well as you know and your viewers will
know there are lots of upsides to using
trees but the problem we've calculated
is that
once you total up the sort of net zero
commitments that big
companies and country or governments are
making
you end up with a ludicrous total of the
land that's going to be needed
in new forests and our estimate is that
it could need as much as 1.6
billion hectares between now and 2050
of new forests in order to meet the net
zero targets i mean that's the
area of five times uh india for example
and it's equivalent
to the amount of arable farmland that's
in use today
and so if you know that sounds to us
like a ludicrous amount of
land that's just impossible to reach and
of course even if we came
close to meeting those sorts of targets
the problem may be
that uh we'll be using valuable precious
farmland and
and and planting that with trees with
forests rather than using it to grow the
food that the world population will need
and
you know we're already seeing rising
hunger rising food prices
and if there's a sort of land grab for
carbon sinks for new forests
uh this is not going to help in terms of
the fight against poverty
and a lot of people say it's a vital
tool in
reducing carbon emissions because trees
suck in carbon and they're also really
good for biodiversity as well
so what are you suggesting as an
alternative well i think just to
just to clarify here that you know it is
a vital tool but it doesn't seem quite
right that the world's
largest oil and gas companies for
example continue to exploit
new fossil fuel uh fields you know a
plan to be pumping out new carbon and
then are planning to offset that
with uh with new forests and that
doesn't seem right because
what we really need is urgent action to
reduce emissions
quickly dramatically it also means not
um
opening up new fields and new production
of oil and gas and so i think that's a
problem there
the other one of course is that a lot of
the most intense
ways of capturing carbon uh involve
large monoculture forests you know using
trees like eucalyptus or acacia and that
might be great at um
capturing carbon efficiently but it's
not necessarily
good for sustainable agriculture for
biodiversity
for community-based agroforestry which
might need a
different uh approach and so we're
really calling for urgent action to
look at exactly what lies behind the net
zero targets
and of course if it includes forestation
that's great but let's also be sensible
about how we approach
that aforestation as well dani
sriskandar raja thanks very much indeed
scientists are warning that marine life
in the caribbean is at risk of being
contaminated by plastics and other
man-made fibers in the sea the
all-female crew on board the research
vessel
expedition found a majority of these
plastics can be traced back to the
caribbean's tourism and fishing
industries
both vital to the island's economies our
correspondent ashna harinag reports
unsightly and welcome and for a postcard
destination
undesirable
plastics on the shores and seabeds of
caribbean islands
are threatening their futures
this is the finding of a pioneering
all-female crew of scientists
who have spent over two years analyzing
samples on land and sea
already see right here a pretty chunky
piece of white micro plastic and feels
really stiff it's got a jagged edge
that's the sharp eye of emily penn who
is leading the project
her team scoped out the plastic strewn
destinations to try and understand its
origins
a lot of what we were doing this year
was really trying to understand
the sort of chemistry of the plastic
that can then help inform where that
plastics come from because this
soup of micro plastic fragments can be
very anonymous
it doesn't sort of have a brand label
necessarily on it
and i think we were maybe expecting that
it would be very obvious where a lot of
the sources had come from
but they found more than one sector to
blame the fishing industry
maritime industry and also tourism are
very important in the caribbean
but it's a complex challenge because
these appear to be some of the sources
of the plastics that we're finding
their study hopes to encourage more
joined up solutions between
nations antigua for instance has banned
plastic bags
unlike neighbourings and kits this is a
single-use
plastic cutlery and some single-use
styrofoam glasses
the survival of these islands beauty
depends on mankind when every
drop of ocean water could be one plastic
bottle
bag and beach ball away from this
ashna harinac sky news well that's
everything from us for today
on tomorrow's show how climate change is
putting the ancient
world at risk of disappearing thanks for
watching and see you then